okay so the first talk today will be
given by Ken Carson on dimension on that
imaginary reduction continued from
yesterday hi everybody so first of all I
have to express the usual kind of
trepidation that you know that this is
supposed to be boring
most people here will know more about
this than I do
etc etc but you know bear with me I'm
I'll try to explain things and hopefully
uh at least in some cases a fresh way
so yesterday Ravi and David talked about
among other things several different
sketching matrix distributions different
ways randomized ways to generate
sketching matrices some sketching
matrices being matrices so if you
multiply them you compress the matrix in
a way that preserves useful properties
so as far as sampling goes picking rows
at random and I'll just talk about rows
but also it applies to columns of course
there is a uniform sampling just pick
uniformly at random and this this is of
course very fast and it's like the one
case where you could or you could have
you have a sub linearity right you don't
even have to look at all the data you
just pick it at random and there you go
but you don't typically have the kind of
the good theoretical bounds that you
might hope for have those only in
certain kinds of special cases and then
there's what Ravi called
length squared sampling you use sample
proportional to the to the Euclidean
length of the row of the matrix and
those give some some theoretical bounds
they're they're additive they're not the
best that can be done in all cases in
terms of linear combinations so I'm
regarding sketching I'm regarding as
being all of these kinds of ways of
compressing matrices and in the case of
sketching via linear combinations
there's the johnson lyndon truss which
is kind of the granddaddy or maybe
banana of them all the the first of
these witches uses a random orthogonal
matrix that can be in a sense simplified
to use independent identically
distributed gaussians just you know just
independent Gaussian
there's the subsampled random
Hadamard transform the David mentioned
yesterday and there's Count sketch which
is which is gives very fast algorithms
but at least with respect to some
parameters maybe not in all cases with
respect to the the error parameters but
gives very nice algorithms including
kind of denser versions of it where you
you you do work which is not for the
sketch which is not proportional to the
number of nonzero entries but some
multiple of that so today I'll try to
fill in of this a little bit and talk
about leverage score sampling as I think
it was mentioned yesterday which is a
way of sampling rows of matrices such
that you get the good properties from
for the sketches such as subspace
embeddings and and good approximate
matrix multiplication and those two
things together give quite a number of
different you have quite a number of
different useful features for for matrix
computations for you know regression for
low-rank approximation and so on I'll
try to give some something of an
analysis of SR HT depending in part on
on leverage score results and then time
permitting which I'm kind of hoping it
won't but time permitting I'll talk
about I'll talk about kernels and in
that case mostly random Fourier features
so first of all the first topic then
there's leverage score sampling in
particular sampling so how do you kind
of implement row sampling as a matrix
well you just have a matrix whose rows
are multiples of natural basis vectors
okay so so if we're sampling a matrix a
which is an N by D matrix and we have a
Santro sampling matrix which is M by n
then each row of s times a will be some
multiple as we choose of a row of a so
so here's one of these here sampling
matrices where just one nonzero entry
per row here's the rows of a and here's
the resulting sort of compressed version
pick picking out samples picking out
rows of a okay so this is this is all
very well uniform length weighted length
linked at squared sampling etc so so the
question here is is are there sampling
matrix distributions of this kind rows
sampling say the matrix distributions so
that with high probability for any acts
you can you have some it's true that s
times a times X has a norm which is
within one plus or minus epsilon or at
least you're just approximately equal to
in some sense the norm of a times X so
another way to say that is that s takes
the subspace with of of RN which is the
column span of a the image of a under
under multiplication so it's it's you
know vectors of the form a times X for X
and Rd takes that takes that column span
which I'm writing is as image just
because it's shorter it's an another
terminology people use takes that
subspace into RM and approximately
preserves lengths so that it's an
embedding in that sense so we're looking
for sampling matrices distributions over
sampling matrices that give us subspace
embeddings okay so just as a general way
of describing a sampling distribution
suppose you have some some vector in in
RN which as entries between 0 & 1 so
it's sort of a probability vector each
each entry of it gives you some
probability and the way that you
construct a sampling matrix from it is
for each row for each for each I yeah
from 1 to n with probability P sub I you
wouldn't you include in your sampling
matrix the corresponding multiple of the
natural basis vector and there's a
scaling by the square root of P sub I
which which will which is a good thing
as seen in the next line so this is one
way to construct a sampling matrix doing
it independently in a sense
sampling each row of of the input matrix
of the of the matrix that you ultimately
will be looking at okay so for one thing
with this scaling the the result is an
unbiased estimator of the square of the
norm of a times X so if you fix X and
then look at what you get out of this
the the squared norm of s times a times
X and an expectation at least you get
the right answer you get that the result
of that is the squared norm of a times X
and then just as a you know so my style
here will be that that here's a here's a
factual statement a theorem let's say
and here's here's a proof so you can
ignore the indented code you know
greenish colored parts if you want they
you don't need them further for the rest
of the discussion but this is just a
just an argument that that indeed you
get an unbiased estimator because the
scale appropriately so that the so that
the probability term cancels out okay so
what do you want out of one of these
probability vectors and the
corresponding distribution first of all
you you want the number of rows that you
generate in this way which is itself a
random variable you want that to not be
too big it's just the sum of the
expected value of this and it
concentrates nicely of course is that is
that is the is the sum of these piece of
ice and then what you want out of it is
that the resulting matrix is with with
high probability a subspace and Bay okay
so as I mentioned you know if you you
could do uniform sampling which would
more or less correspond to a piece of I
which is which is proportional to one
over N for all I you could do link
squared sampling which is where P sub I
is proportional to the squared norm of
the row a sub I and that's my my
notation for the I throw which is a sub
I star but you know neither of these
things are necessarily terrifically well
behaved because you could have some some
row that has a very law it was very high
length but the X that you happen to pick
is is perpendicular to it is orthogonal
to it
so you get a zero in that case or it
could be that you have some a sub I
times X which is large and the other
entries are small and so you you you you
know that bad guy has an inordinate
effect overall or is David give a couple
of other examples yesterday of how you
can kind of go wrong with sampling in
terms of get ending up with the wrong
rank and so on so so you know uniform
sampling length squared sampling don't
have the nicest behavior and in general
what we want is that these terms which
we which we generate you know one over
the square root of P sub I times a sub I
the the wrote the I throw dotted with x
over all X and all I we want those to be
well-behaved whatever whatever that
means
so one notion of well-behaved is that
every one of these guys has kind of a
bounded relative contribution to the
thing that is being estimated which is
the squared norm of of a times X so you
know if we look at it in those terms
then the I throw contributes the square
of AI of AI dot x2 to this sum so one
thing that we could look for is a P sub
I that is an upper bound on that
contribution on that relative
contribution to the to to this thing
that we're estimating so suppose we find
some some values P sub I such that we
have this upper bound bounding this
maximum a relative contribution okay so
if we use that for sampling then then
all of the some bands that we look at
will in in this thing in in if we if we
compare our estimate to what we're
estimating and then and then expand that
out then we get something where every
one of the some ads is is bounded by one
so it sits nicely behaved in that sense
and here so the the I have an indicator
variable which is Delta sub I which is
one if we happen to choose that
and zero otherwise so are just
parenthetically are there any questions
so far okay so so with these this
particular set of P sub I we we have
nicely uniform and in some sense uniform
some ads that were that we're using here
okay and so if we look at that in terms
of you know the concentration and and
tail estimates and so on then what we
have is is a is a particular s tomater
in which each random variable it's a sum
of some x by in which each random
variable X sub I is bounded so from that
we can get concentration we can get a
tail estimate by Bernstein's inequality
as or you know generalizations thereof
as Ravi talked about yesterday and
there's just quoting Bernstein's
inequality to remind you and and as as
in the kind of argument that David
mentioned yesterday with this
concentration we can just use a Union
bound that would hold for any less is
some exponential number of distinct
vectors that we pick and then via that
if we papen to pick those vectors to be
the vectors of an epsilon net then we
there's a standard argument that says
that we can extend the the goodness of
the approximation that we get from the
from the vectors of the epsilon net to
to all vectors okay so we from the
boundedness of these of these sum adds
we end up with with with good
concentration and and actually we get a
subspace embedding there there is an
another argument which here which
involves matrix Bernstein which which i
won't i won't go into okay and and as i
will see a little a little later the
some of these p sub i's is is actually
equal to d if we if we pick the the
smallest P sub I that is a that
large enough according to that
description and and with that then we
get a we can get a relative error
epsilon by using about D over epsilon
squared samples
okay so just by plugging into what that
means in the Bernstein yeah question
because that's the scaling of the this
isn't you're talking about here yeah so
so this isn't the expectation of the of
this quantity this is this is what we
would actually get from one instance
right okay
right so we use matrix we use the
Bernstein's inequality we use the
boundedness we use an epsilon net and we
have we have a subspace embedding in
this case with this particular
construction okay so so where do these P
sub I come from what would how do we how
do we get them what do they what do they
mean well okay so we want if we went it
for in it for over X we want to find the
soup for each row of the square of a sub
I X divided by the squared norm of AX
okay so suppose that a has a
decomposition u times R where where u is
an orthonormal matrix so so so each each
column of U is orthogonal to every other
column the columns are unit vectors and
so if we look at u transpose u we get
the identity matrix okay so so u or in
other words you as a so we say is a
basis for the column space of of a okay
so if we have that then we can
understand this Suprema mat we're
looking at in terms of it so we we
replace the eighth row of a by the I
throw of U times R X and we replace a by
u times R and that in the denominator as
well and and we're looking at the soup
over X of youth of that quantity or
equivalently we could look at just the
soup over over vectors Y of the dot
product of the I throw of U with y
divided by the squared norm of u times y
now since since u is this orthogonal
basis collection of orthodontist and
orthonormal matrix the the norm of U
times y is equal to the norm of Y so we
get we get this expression here and now
and now we want to find the the
the the Y which maximises that term and
people sometimes ask for you know okay
okay tell me what this is but I think I
will just tell you instead what you want
to do is as sorry is to pick the Y which
is the unit vector Y in the dura in the
direction of that I throw so that would
be that would be the thing that would
maximize the dot product with that ayah
with that I throw of you you want to
pick that particular vector Y and as a
consequence the supremum is just the
squared norm of that row of the of the
of that matrix so so what do we do we we
picked we start out with a we computed
an orthogonal basis of its column space
of its of its image and then we looked
at the squared norm of the rows of that
thing okay so so one one thing here is
well what if we picked another you some
other decomposition wouldn't you know
wouldn't that you know why why don't we
get something else well what we started
with here is for this is for the given a
and that supreme um is going to remain
fixed no matter what so it doesn't
matter what you we happen to pick we're
gonna have those squared norms of you be
the same because they're all going to
equal this guy they're all going to
equal that that's supremo okay so so the
particular choice of basis does not
matter you end up with the same thing
another small point here is that which
if you think about taking this
orthogonal basis and then looking at the
squared norm of the rows you know what's
the particular bond on that well it's
also clear from this that the that that
the squared norm of that of that row can
be at most one because the supreme amost
one because you have a term divided by a
sum of positive values that includes
that term so so the the the leverage
scores which is what I've been
describing as as discussed here the
leverage scores are bounded by one which
is which is useful for some purposes and
actually they're they're all so small on
average
so if you were to look at the some of
these pieces of ice and the piece again
that would be the the expected number of
rows of the of the sampling matrix that
were we're gonna get that song is is
equal to the sum of the squared norms of
the rows of this or thigh of this
orthonormal matrix so that's equal to
the just the sum of all of the entries
the squared entries the the Frobenius
norm which is equal to the sum of the
squared norms of the columns of that
matrix and each column of that matrix is
a unit norm and there's d of them so so
the sum here is d okay so that's the the
thing that I claimed on you know the
slide or so ago that that the sum of the
leverage scores is D which me which
gives gives a kind of a grip on how big
the sampling matrix needs to be in order
to have the the subspace and breading
embedding properties that we want and
you would just do the obvious thing
which is X to be that's exactly that's
exactly yeah so I'm doing that in a more
long-winded way yeah what yeah okay
yeah so okay so so yeah it's it's that's
that's one version of what leverage
scores are and and so I'm gonna I'm
going to talk a bit about how to compute
them but it's also of interest just
there they have a remarkable number of
interesting connections which I will not
go into in detail but for example if if
you know you you matrices you of this
kind with orthonormal columns one
version of talking one way of talking
about their rows is to say that the rows
are a set of points which are in
isotropic position okay this is a
terminology which goes back some time
and and so you could in some sense you
could say you're starting out with some
set of points this cloud of points and
then D correlating it you're making it
kind of nicely shaped or you know
rounding it in a certain sense so that
so it's so it's sample covariance matrix
is the identity and then and then having
done that then you're doing link squared
sampling in of the of the resulting set
of points okay so that's a somewhat more
and I have by a somewhat bad picture
over here of here's my cloud of nine of
points and here's my subset the za so
this this this terminology and this
construction came up was was discussed
by Mark Wilson many years ago and this
paper is actually still on archive
curiously and it was motivated by work
related to estimating the volume of
convex bodies in in in the sense of
trying to come up with a transformation
which at least part of this has to do
with the transformation that tries to
get the the points and the points of the
convex body that infinite set of points
in the convex position and this is an
argument that you can do that
approximately by taking appropriate
samples of the of the points rudl s'en
and and vershinin also looked at this
for a kind of species of course set for
minimum and closing ellipsoid so you're
given a set of points
he would have find a subset so that the
minimum enclosing the ellipsoid of the
subset is is very close in in a certain
sense in Banach measure distances is
very close in a certain sense to the
true minimum and closing ellipsoid of
the set of points and and in a in a very
different terminology rudl son and
vershinin showed that this kind of
construction gives you these corsets
okay so there's a there's a relationship
here to estimating the volume of convex
bodies there's also a fairly direct
relationship as I think Robby alluded to
to spectral specification and effective
resistance in which you can think about
it I think Michael and and at all have
papers discussing this in particular
that if you look at leverage score
sampling of the vertex edge incidence
matrix of an undirected graph then
essentially that that's the key thing
that you need to do in order to do
spectral sparsa fication so when you do
a sampling according to effective
resistance in a sense you're doing
leverage score sampling
okay now we're also also of course
motivated by doing regression both least
squares regression and l1 regression and
that's oh and and and for for other
sorry for other P is well LP regression
for other P and that's also possible and
and this kind of thing can also be
applied to low-rank approximation both
in our various robust settings in terms
of I think entry wise an error measure
for low-rank approximation which is
entry wise is maybe the most interesting
version of this and there and and and
David and company have papers about that
there's also the possibility of doing
something which is an error which is the
sum of the of the the sum of the
Euclidean norms of the rows and that's
somewhat more robust than than for B
Gnaeus norm but less robust then entry
was l1 norm and sampling is is important
for that of course as as I think David
mentioned this is also used in Cyr
decomposition in which you want to have
a low-rank approximation in which
there's a matrix E which is comprises
columns a subset of the columns of the
input matrix a and a matrix R which can
probably whose rows are comprised of
sorry composed of rows of the input
matrix a and then some some matrix U in
between which which makes which is makes
it work which
it gives you the best approximate you
can subject to having that matrix and
you know for you find the best such
matrix you can and prove that you have
good approximation based on it so the at
least some of the titles of my sites or
reference sensitivity and what I mean
there is this kind of the the for it for
a given if you have a loss function
which is sum of terms the sensitivity of
the ithe term would be the the maximum
relative contribution that it makes to
the loss over all arguments to the to
the loss function so that would be one
notion of sort of sensitivity of that
particular law and and so in the case of
leverage score sampling that's the the
contribution of that the loss is the is
the squared norm of a times X and and
you're looking at the the relative
contribution that it makes maximized
over all X but you could also people
have also thought about this with
respect to think projective clustering
where you're fitting a number of
subspaces to a to a set of points
they've discussed it in the context of
even k-means and and andres crows i
think has a has an upper as a as a some
work in which with co-authors they they
give a an outlier detection scheme in
which they regard the high sensitivity
points where the sensitivity is with
respect to k-means clustering they have
they if they regard such points as
outliers and remove them and similarly
here you get even in the case of l2
regression i think it would be at least
one kind of procedure that people might
do which is to find these high leverage
score points and instead of you know
preferentially sampling them to get you
as close as possible to to the to the
true anta to the you know the least
squares answer you might actually also
just want to remove them because they
they're contributing too much they're
not they're they're punching above their
weight in terms of you know their
they're doing too much relative to what
you want your typical data points to do
so
so sensitivity in jet has some has a
more general conception and in that more
general conception it's often used as a
as a way of defining outliers so turning
to how to how to compute these things
and and here I guess the the the
starting point would be that you do a QR
factorization so that would be n times d
squared for this n times d n by D input
matrix but an alternative is to use
sketching to get a change of basis
matrix which allows you to get something
that's close to being an orthogonal
basis and here I'm I in some sense I'm
just repeating what David talked about
yesterday
because the matrix matrices involved and
the constructions we're using are pretty
much the same as what he discussed with
reference to high accuracy least squares
regression okay which is to say but you
know with a with a few wrinkles in
because we're not doing least squares
regression we're doing something else ok
so here's here's here's the algorithm
before talking about too much about what
it means so there's something you put
matrix a there is a subspace epsilon
embedding matrix S which which is M by n
which which works for a and here here
I'm actually talking not about sampling
so I want to use leverage scores to do
sampling because I want to get an
epsilon embedding but in order to do
that I have to have the leverage scores
in order to do that I need I'm using
another subspace embedding but in fact
we can use for that purpose count sketch
and and variance and so on in order to
so we apply one one kind of subspace
embedding in order to compute another
kind of subspace embedding that we want
okay so so we have some let's say count
sketch subspace embedding matrix s and
also a JL matrix which would meaning
would have the property that if we if
you take a row vector ax and we multiply
it by this matrix pi
then we get a vector whose norm is
within 1 plus epsilon 1 plus or minus
epsilon of the norm of X so but we just
need that for some set of n Rho vector
some set some set of n fixed vectors
okay and here the this this JL matrix
PI will be D by n prime where M prime is
is log n over epsilon squared ok so so
there's the input
there's the sketching matrix s which
will be applied on the left and there's
a sketchy and a gel matrix PI which will
be implied on the right and so what do
we do we compute the sketch of W which
is s times a we compute not the QR
inverse decomposition but the QR
decomposition sorry of W of this sketch
and and then compute a the sketch using
PI of of a time's our inverse where I
put the parentheses here put the for R
inverse times pi specifically because if
we if we compute the prod the product of
a times R inverse times pi in that way
then we it's cheaper the overall work
that we do is less if we if we do it in
that order and then finally in this
peculiar matte Latta matte lavish
notation we're returning the the dot
products of the of the rows of of that
matrix Z ok so so what did what did we
do here we we just we just returned the
the squares of its row norms so the Z is
standing in for ultimately for the
orthogonal basis of a and so we computed
squared norms instead of instead of the
norms of a true orthogonal basis and or
this is a sketch of an approximate
orthogonal basis of a you
before yeah so so so I had a matrix you
before which is yeah which I was looking
to find the leverage scores in terms of
the squared norms of the rows of you
that was an orthogonal basis for the
column span of a Anna and and that's too
expensive to compute here so we do we
get close to it by by using sketching
and and you know the up to up to minor
changes the notation you know we're
doing the same thing as David did just
described yesterday for for
preconditioners so so yeah so so our
inverse is something that that so yeah
so so W is that w is the sketch and and
if you applied R inverse on on the right
to the sketch then you'd have an
orthogonal matrix because it's because Q
R equals si so so si R inverse is equal
to Q so so R inverse is a matrix that is
is you know at least as far as the
sketch goes makes something you know
very well conditioned you know it's
orthis an orthogonal basis and the thing
is that because it's a sketch you're
you're you because you have this change
of basis that really works well for this
sketch it also works kind of okay for
the original matrix so so as I have here
that that a times R inverse is very well
conditioned which is to say that it has
singular values which are 1 plus or
within put 1 plus or minus epsilon
within that within that interval 1 minus
epsilon 1 plus Epsilon ok and then so
here's here's you know here's the
dilemma and here's the proof which just
looks at all X and if you look at the
norm of a R inverse times X then because
of because s is a subspace embedding you
know
I was hoping yeah there we go because s
this is subspace embedding you know the
norm of a R inverse times X is is within
1 plus or minus epsilon of the norm of s
times a R inverse times X and a s times
a times our inverse is is Q is that is
that the Q of the orthogonal
decomposition or sorry the QR
decomposition of s times a and so that's
that's equal to Q ton of the norm of Q
times X but because Q is an orthonormal
basis that's just the norm of X so so a
times our inverse takes any ax and
produces something whose norm is going
to be within 1 plus or minus epsilon of
the norm of X and that's as as one yes
hopefully it's not too too hard to see
that that that's equivalent to saying
that a time's our inverse has singular
values which are which are very close to
one which are within 1 1 minus epsilon 1
plus epsilon so yeah subject to pretty
colors but yeah ok so so now suppose we
actually have you this is the same you
as before it's an orthonormal basis for
the column span of a then then the thing
is that yeah a a times R inverse is sort
of morally alike like this like this guy
it's so it's it's it's a basis but it's
and it's almost orthogonal but not quite
so suppose we pick some a matrix T that
kind of translates between the two so
that a times R inverse times T is equal
to u okay that and so we can pick such a
matrix by solving an appropriate system
then then T also has singular values
which are 1 plus or minus epsilon and
and then there's one line of argument to
to show that that's the case again based
on just examining any ex and seeing what
T does to that ex and and again using a
subspace and betting properties of s and
then a matrix that has singular values
that are 1 plus or minus epsilon has has
an inverse whose singular values are are
also very close to epsilon just because
the singular values of the inverse are
the reciprocals of the singular values
of the original matrix and so for small
enough epsilon you get you you could say
that you're within 1 plus or minus 2
epsilon and and various sharper
statements than that maybe I want to say
you know epsilon less than a third and
so on but it's it's all good and and now
the algorithm output is is AEI
transposed which just selects the I
throw it's the I throw of a times R
inverse times pi and the claim is that
that that's within 1 plus or minus
epsilon within oh of sorry let's uh it's
it's within 1 plus or minus o of epsilon
of the norm of the I throw of you but
that that value is the levered score
that were attempting to compute okay so
so why is that well we picked we picked
pi in order to make this first
approximation true it's a it's a JL
matrix more or less and and this is true
by by the argument about no sorry what
why is this true by by definition of T
and and then this is true by this
argument about the singular values of T
inverse so so this scheme works to
estimate the the leverage scores of of
the matrix a yeah
so so having having pie makes things a
little faster because instead of having
to you know actually quite a lot faster
because in we we don't want to compute
that we so we construct a times our
inverse let's say implicitly we have
that matrix and but we don't want to
actually compute a times our inverse and
compute the norm of its rows we want to
estimate then we we're satisfied with an
estimate of the row norms of a times R
inverse and and to get that estimate
week we can speed things up by first
sort of projecting our informal T'Pau
inverse by a by a thin matrix okay okay
right and yeah well so so so M prime is
what is a D over epsilon square yeah so
so so so a has only has only rank D
right it's an N by D matrix and M prime
is bigger than D so yeah yeah so
it's a even much bigger than yeah so
yeah okay okay so so this is yeah yeah
no let me just M prime is M prime well
so there's an M which is the actually
the in this the notation you're
referring to the number of rows of s
which is which is some M which I guess I
haven't actually specified yet but it's
in fact it's you know it's it's bigger
than D significantly bigger than D yeah
yeah yeah yeah but but that's but at the
point that we're using the PI which was
where the M Prime comes we were we're
past that stage so to speak all right I
think M prime is smaller than oh yeah
yeah right it's it's so because all all
all this this projection on the right
this PI matrix all it has to do is to
preserve the norms of n rows of you know
and fixed rows of a matrix not a whole
subspace or anything like that just
those n rows of that of that matrix okay
sure
simply lost when you want to play by the
play is it yeah I hope not
I'm sure no I'm sorry I'm special you
mean like so it's a it's a triangular
matrix or yeah or something I mean it's
actually I think I'm even considering
the possibility of it of Abe having
rankle you know you could consider all
of this with a having rank less than
less than B in which case you know but
no yeah so we're not the you just were
just basically doing straightforward I
mean even even if we explicitly computed
our inverse I I guess we're you were in
a sense we're taking your it's a good
point that we're taking advantage of the
special structure in that we're we're
applying we're multiplying our inverse
and n PI and yes you as as you point out
it because it's triangular that we can
we can apply our inverse quickly so I
guess that is that is helpful to us
although I'm not you know given it might
come out in the wash that we could even
pasta I'm not sure but we could even
possibly just you know compute our
inverse and and so on because the what
the game here is to try to have a
dependence which is how about have an
algorithm whose dependence on on the
number of rows is very small we're not
we're not hoping to do have a dependence
on the number of columns which is you
know which is so small so I understand
so Z is essentially the in our thought
matrix morally a art because you get
that from the our inverse you want to
read up well thanks and so you you the
only thing you want to get is the row
links and so you ya willing to destroy
the structure in our inverse per se by
doing that pi as long as you preserve
that rolling yeah and you would have
gotten the row lengths to Fred's
question to get done that but you just
do it a bit faster because that PI yes
the steps
so so yeah and I wrote I had it had
explicit parentheses so to do the
associative multiplication and the right
and the right order to be the as fast as
possible estimate these leverage scores
as small as epsilon T to be so uh so
that's that
that's the the next slide or well no
actually it isn't it's a couple slides
ahead but just we don't need them to be
that we we could we could pick actually
constant epsilon and for most purposes
that would be fine in fact we don't even
need that log n over epsilon squared in
some cases we can we can get rid of that
because we can you know she even even to
that degree but so I was going to talk
about the running time of this algorithm
and and when we have a sparse embedding
then then it's if it has some sparsity
parameter s so the number of nonzero
entries in a column is at most s then
they then mote then computing this
sketch will take nnz of a times s time
at most computing the the QR
decomposition of the sketch is going to
take d squared times m m being the
number of rows of the sketch the
computation of this guy's e when done in
this particular order first we multiply
our inverse times m prime and and
tomorrow's point this I guess this this
this particular version is taking
advantage of a fast application of our
inverse to the to the columns of pi and
then having done that we have M prime
columns and for each one of those M
prime columns we do n NZ work to
multiply that column vector by the
matrix a so we have N and Z of a times M
prime and then finally we we compute
these dot products for this n by M prime
matrix and that takes o of n times M
prime time so the grand total here is
something where the leading term so to
speak is is the number of nonzero
entries of a but it includes all
one over epsilon squared includes log n
and then there are lower order terms
that are polynomial and D and in one
over epsilon and there's there's that
there's a various technology so Michael
Cohen has has some results and I'm now I
vote of course Jelani Nelson and we when
have had results about the the best
trade-off for the sparsity of s to the
to the dimension of the other sketch and
I think and David talked about this
yesterday I think the the Michael Cohen
had gave the the best such trade-off I'm
not sure that using this particular
trade office is too significant here
however okay so just to state this in
just to put a put a box around it we can
compute the leverage scores with
relative error epsilon in this time
which is N and Z of a times one over
epsilon squared times so again plus
terms that are polynomial and in d + 1
over epsilon okay so so as I mentioned
before in response to dozens question
for many purposes such as this leverage
score sampling constant epsilon is fine
and and in some cases it's actually
possible to to cheat even more in the
sense that you don't need a full JL you
can you can use only one over epsilon
squared columns in your in your JL
matrix and that's still good enough for
for the sampling to work for some
purposes and if if you were to do that
then in order to get get the you you
want to use the particular sparsity
parameters so that you would then be
able to say that your leading term and
your running time is n n Z of a over you
know poly poly one over epsilon but
epsilon can be constant so yeah
so what if you want better approximation
of the Leopards
then epsilon being constant like because
it's something this will I mean this
approach seems to go back to this sort
of empty square triangle time right if
epsilon is like one of the thieves we'll
find out well if epsilon is really small
then this doesn't this doesn't gain
anything yeah yeah but I don't I don't
know of any kind of iterative
improvement ish you know gradient
descent ish kind of methods that would
apply in this case I guess the thing is
it's not it's not for for algorithmic
purposes it's not it's not super well
motivated I guess I guess people you
know statisticians are interested in
leverage scores as such and in which
case they want to actually have good
estimates of them but this is this is
what I know
okay yeah was the last point whether
something oh so so if you wanna if you
want a Jael estimate that gives you know
that preserves norms of the rows when
you multiply on the right by that pie
matrix then then you needed you know
jail thing would say that you need log n
over epsilon squared but yeah but if
yeah you can if you if you want to do
leverage score sampling then there are
cases where you can you can forget about
that where you can get by kind of
without it you can shave up look in this
you can shave off the log in which which
says in particular that you don't have
that log in in your leading term anymore
it increases the number of things that
are in NZ of a you know within the
leading term without any other stuff in
it of by the way for that question and
there are hardness results like if you
want all the effective resistance is up
to a very fine accuracy then you can do
better that matrix multiplication time
under some reductions so like one of our
public ones us want to pull in
approximations so there's a new camera
and yes this year may be a question but
how do you know you have a good
approximation
the risk was renovated by Loretta
yeah and how do you know that you have a
good subspace you know well so so if you
apply it to least squares regression
then then you know you can see what
happens when you use it right so I think
I think if you were to use the leverage
scores for sampling then I think in
various algorithmic I mean that there's
a lot of these things where the were the
result of the the failure probability is
only constant it's not super small but
if you if you you you can easily tell
that you fail for that particular
algorithmic application now leverage
scores as such being able to tell that
you're that you're good I don't I don't
know I don't think so
but
yeah okay so that's the first third of
my talk and now for but I'll go more
quickly over the rest of it
so David talked yesterday about the
subsampled randomized Hadamard transform
where the motivation here is that is
that they're either with the with jl
where you use a a dense orthogonal
matrix or random gaussians where again a
dense matrix computing the sketch is
slow fast JL as introduced by alone and
Chazelle kind of improved that by
applying by using cases in which you
have an orthogonal matrix which you can
apply quickly and this SR HT is a
variant of that which is I think a
little easier to understand which
involves just Hadamard matrices as
opposed to Fourier transforms and and so
I think is advantageous in those senses
so this this construction is a bit
simpler and a bit cleaner than than the
original fast JL I think it it could be
argued as as David described yesterday
this this this transform is a is a
product that say there's a matrix a
diagonal matrix D which is a sign matrix
in the sense of has random plus or minus
ones on the diagonal there's an H matrix
which is a Hadamard matrix and there's a
P which is matrix which is just does
implements uniform sampling of the rows
of HD
and how do more matrices have a
recursive construction to go from H i 2h
i plus one you you can you could
describe h i plus 1 in terms of h i have
the four blocks which are H I H I H I
and minus H I and then you scale that by
1 over root 2 and having applied that
recursively H you have for for a given
order for a given K you have HK which is
a 2 K by 2 K matrix
2 to the K by 2 to the K matrix of plus
or minus 1 values and it's scaled by the
square root of its order it scaled by 1
over 2 to the K over 2 okay so so
there's that recursive construction and
one can easily verify that this thing is
orthogonal just by looking at it block
wise and and applying the recursive
construction one can show that you can
have a fast multiply also recursively by
by splitting a given vector that you're
applying the multiplication to into two
pieces
applying the multiplication that's each
and then and then to build the product
out of those the products for those two
pieces you just add them through those
results or subtract them the upshot is
that you have n log n to compute H times
x-4 for a in vector X and now the
analysis of this involves looking at the
leverage scores of of the of H times D
times a so this the it was P times H
times D so the last step is just uniform
sampling and so uniform sampling doesn't
work in general but it does work well if
the leverage scores are all uniformly
bounded and so the the upshot of this
analysis is to show that the the
leverage scores are approximately
bounded in this way and and so so the
first step is just bound those leverage
scores of H times T times a and then in
the second step is to show that leverage
score sampling in that case behaves well
as it as it will for these nice uniform
scores I'm not sure how I'm gonna spend
the next five minutes I guess I'll just
continue until I well I'm not gonna go
over too much but I'll see if I could
come to some conclusion so okay so so
how do we show that the leverage scores
of H times the times a are well behaved
and and I should say kind of the the
intuition here is that is the D is kind
of randomly scrambling it's just sign
flipping the rows of a that's what
multiplying by D will do and then H
times D times a is taking taking these
randomly flip things and doing an
orthogonal transformation of them so the
upshot is you're kind of scrambling the
leverage scores of a in in this nice way
in a way which results in uniformity
okay so so the first observation is that
because the construction is oblivious
not because the neither P nor H nor D
has to look at the matrix a in order to
in order to be constructed we're we're
actually making a statement not about
the particular input matrix a itself in
a sense we're making a statement about
the column span of a about a particular
subspace and how this transform behaves
on that subspace so as a consequence
instead of thinking about what happens
with an arbitrary matrix a we can just
kind of assume that a is an orthogonal
basis that it that it has orthonormal
columns and and as a constant and so in
the rest of this particular discussion
I'll assume that a is actually equal to
U for for this orthonormal basis you
because because it doesn't you know we
can just assume that without loss of
generality in this oblivious case okay
so with that assumption H times Z times
a has orthonormal columns and so the the
we have an orthonormal matrix and so we
want to we want to get its leverage
scores but in that case we just need to
know the row norms of this orthogonal
matrix H times D times a
get a get a bound on them and the the
way that the analysis proceeds is to
look at the look at something which is a
function of the diagonal matrix D which
is the the norm of the I throw of H
times D times a as a function of D and
and the analysis then goes look show
first shows that the expected value of
that function is is it most root of D
over N so it's it's very it's it's some
sort of as small as it could is it could
be in some sense it's it's as small as
what you would yeah you know very very
uniform and then the argument shows that
that this function f is convex and if
Lipschitz and then through the magic of
Ladue 96 there is a tail estimate for
for Rademacher vectors such as the
diagonal of d as arguments two convex
Lipschitz functions and and so that gets
a tail estimate a concentration bound
for for F of D and then having having
gotten that concentration and that low
expectation then it's just a Union bound
over the rows in order to to have to
show that all of the leverage scores of
H times D times they are are small
so so first of all there here's here's a
here's the the argument that the the F
of D is is small and expectation so F of
D is the is that is the expected value
of that that thing is the expected value
of that of that the norm of that I throw
so if we look at the square of it we can
bound it by the expectation of the
square because if that didn't hold in
the variances variances could be
negative so we look at the expectation
of the square which we can describe as
the the sum of the its its entries of
the the the d entries of that row the
sum of the squares of the d entries of
that row and a typical and entry of that
row is is this natural basis vector e AI
transpose it's selecting the I throw
times H times D times the J column of a
okay
and so the Jade column of a bar by
assumption is actually a unit vector and
the the yai transpose times H times D is
a is a vector that's of plus and minus
ones scaled by 1 over root n that's the
1 over 2 to the K over 2 and and just
using that then it there's not even an
expectation it has to be that the value
of that entry has to be at most of that
of that squared value has to be at most
1 over N and so we get that the
expectation of this the squared
expectation of F of D is at most the sum
over these D columns of 1 over N which
is d over N and so we did an expectation
which of F of D which is bounded by D
over n the square root of D over N is
claimed so I think sorry there was no D
this argument wouldn't change but they
was really important so let's see it
comes in it comes in as a as a function
here I'm not I'm not quite sure how to
how to how to answer that in the sense I
mean it you know in and out you need mmm
yeah it comes in but if by the
concentration results so it's the only
random thing right and and the fact that
it's it's bounded in expectation that
this is well so so this step required is
is looking at the that the expectation
the rest of it is not looking at the
expectation but the the first step is
what you're talking about Big D diagonal
matrix yeah yeah maybe it's important in
some other stuff looks like it's not
important in this stuff I'm not sure
what yeah
so rather compliment that show
sorry about the benefactor because yeah
if you don't the D it's just overall
hard about matrix but you want to make
yeah so so so I mean the bright yeah 8 D
times H each each row of that will be
will be assigned in fact or Rademacher
vector as you say there will be you know
dependencies among those of course but
but yeah that's that's I mean that's
that's fundamentally what's helping you
I guess I mean the question of what this
particular part of the analysis you know
needs the randomness for is not is not
it's not yeah maybe you have an answer
yeah yeah yeah so in your step you want
the leverage cause of to be
like daunted but if you didn't have the
deep that 11 she goes that they say it
could be good like yeah yeah I mean
that's certainly true
retsu the uniform I is localization
right but there's a small chance that
you localize something that's spread out
so the D basically what's that that case
tell you well the the the the I mean
these are all correct answers but
they're not sort of directly addressing
the particular aspect of you know like
what is what is D important in this
slide in this sense but yeah your last
poll here you say that some dot product
squared equals a norm squared over n is
that true in general is that we train
expectation so so let me see if I had
this as expectation but then it occurred
to me that that maybe I didn't need it
because
let's see let's see let's see so so we
have a vector of we have the
transporters HD is a is a signed vector
and so if we take its dot product with
with this unit vector and the square of
it
isn't that where you expect all the
cross terms disappear yeah but that's
what I'm here okay so okay thank you
okay
so in this step I did actually need an
expectation is that the yeah okay okay
right thank you thank you everyone
okay so I think I will I will have to
more or less end here the in outline the
as before they showed that F of D is
convex and Lipschitz you can use SR you
can use this to you can compose this
with count sketch to get something
that's kind of better than both by first
applying count sketch and then applying
this in order to you know count sketch
to be fast and this to be have even
smaller sketches and then I have some
very nice discussion of kernels and
random Fourier features and ending with
also some mention of tensor sketch which
is a way of doing kernels for way of
sketching polynomial kernels and
fast-food which is a way of doing a kind
of a fast jlh method but for for
Gaussian kernels but that's that's
that's that's it for me so thank you
[Applause]
questions
thank you have again